the latest jobs report for december it
showed the economy added 199 thousand a
number below analysts expectations but
the unemployment rate dropped from 4.2
to 3.9 percent that's the lowest it's
been in nearly two years to explain what
it all means we're joined by cbs news
senior business analyst jill schlesinger
jill good morning
good morning
well economists were expecting higher
job creation numbers in both november
and december so why have the numbers
been so off in both cases
you know this is a very tough concept
but when we get this one monthly jobs
report it's based on two different
surveys one survey goes out to
businesses and says hey did you hire
workers if you hired them what did you
pay them how many hours worked the other
survey goes to households it said it
says to the households hey are you
working are you looking for work and
gather some demographic information now
what's really weird about this and
that's really the word we should think
about weird is that one survey showed
199 000 jobs created that was from the
businesses but when you look at the
household survey it says 651
000 people found work last month so two
things are going on number one it looks
like the gap between these two numbers
usually does converge over time number
two we saw the business numbers really
outpaced the household survey earlier in
the year and now we like we're playing a
little catch-up so numbers are subject
to revision but this was a somewhat
weirdo report
i love that we're going to focus on
weird i don't know if that will be part
of this now but do we have an idea of
whether or not this latest wave of
omicron impacted the numbers we saw and
then what the overall year how we can
look at that
well i don't think the variant really
touches this report as much because the
survey week is december 12th and this is
before a lot of businesses shut down and
schools shut down so you know we saw
leisure and hospitality add a bunch of
jobs that's probably going to get
reversed next month overall the labor
market is broadly doing very well and i
just want to take a big picture look at
this in 2021 6.4 million jobs added that
is a record-breaking year of course it
comes on the heels of 2020. 9.4 million
jobs lost also a record-breaking year
but of the more than 22 million jobs
that we lost due to covid we're about 84
of the way back and that's really good
news additionally unemployment rate that
14.7
spike we saw in april of 2020 we're now
down to 3.9 percent and you know what
that is closing in on a 50-year low of
three and a half percent we saw that
three and a half percent print the month
before covet arrived so i think better
we're not all the way there but it is
tremendous progress in under two years
jill in this as you say weird market
when most workers seem to have a lot of
leverage and are quitting jobs and
taking new ones or not how are companies
trying to keep
workers right now in 2022
i think that the most important thing to
remember is they're trying to give
flexibility but they're paying more 4.7
increase in wages year over year that's
important because we know inflation is
running so hot a 6.8
rate right now good news on that is
really that the lower income wages are
rising much more quickly than the medium
and higher end very important as people
contend with these big price increases
all right jill great information as
always thank you